we become a society that feels that
people need to be one-dimensional and
one-trick ponies
why are we not allowed to be double or
triple threats
you know over the last couple of weeks a
lot of people been talking about all the
tech stuff that i've been doing and
they're like wow you know
geez you know about different stuff
besides wine and i gave
gave that a lot of thought how people
are branded and pigeonholed
into being able to do one thing like how
about the people that are such great
actors is one thing you can't see them
as anything else
i mean does anybody really think that
tony soprano is going to be able to do
anything else see
james galvini you know the whole thing
is that we get
pigeonholed in the society and a lot of
people like well you know
now that you're doing this whole tech
thing which i don't even know what that
means
you know did not want to do the wine
thing was the wine thing this and it
gave me
an amazingly interesting couple of weeks
where
i don't think people realize we're
multi-dimensional people you know i know
about the jets i know about wine heck i
know about cheese and tea
and other things and yes i know about
business and philosophy i built a lot of
businesses
from the 100 investment for my baseball
card business that became thousands and
thousand dollars a weekend
i mean i just am surprised that so many
people feel that they need to stick into
one place
i think every person is
multi-dimensional and has enormous
things that they're good at
and many different interests and i think
the best way to communicate
in this new social era is to talk about
all of them don't hide
anything i don't hide the jets thing
from my wine show though it might not
make sense
as a blueprint for a successful wine
video blog i think people will always
embrace
real and authenticity and i think the
more things you talk about that you know
about
things that you're actually passionate
about passionate about
i think the more that people are going
to get to really know who you are
and i think that transparency is the key
and so please don't
fear being multi-dimensional speaking of
a multi-dimensional person i want to
give a humongous
birthday shout out to jason freed a lot
of you people know 37 signals
my link it up oh wait a minute matt's
not here this is gary vaynerchuk.com not
wine library tv so i'm going to link up
37 signals
jason freed is somebody who i'm just
getting to know but as a gentleman that
shows amazing uh amazing skills in
business and in tech and
many other areas so i want to give them
a huge shout out another great example
of a good guy that wins
you know good guys coming in last is so
ridiculous by the way
anyway expand
what you're talking about if it's
something you know you're talking about
if it's something that you know you're
talking about yeah see you later
see i'm real don't even edit that part
out